non alors la première saint valentin
avec toulouse michel ben nous l'avons
passé ajouté
[Musique]
donc on y parle qu'à l'hôtel on a passé
une nuit voilà et puis on est revenu à
la maison
on était à une soirée chez mes parents
c'était au carnaval et à minuit j'ai
reçu
un présent aux cadeaux
[Musique]
lmh lille bons plats et les
odeurs libye lé coup dur donc jean roch
et un dessert aucune idée
un rop un peu comme eux la soupe aux
légumes j'aime bien alors entré chez je
réponds foie gras parce que j'ai
beaucoup le foie gras petit moule à
gratiner au four des fruits de mer
coquilles saint jacques sous n'importe
quelle forme tuba un vendeur de tous et
puis on plane sur premier savait très
simple du de la d'oradour à la vanille
assorti de légumes pays que ça me
convient de largement selon avec
steinhoff fine quelque chose gratin de
christophine avec
des langoustes a et al
roba les
bananes john qu'un petit poisson des
nazairiens ont peu de riz et de
lentilles
je ne sais pas trop il adoli par exemple
les normes be le lobby du moins les
hoops 1 il aime aussi le gigot bon geste
des saint-jacques sa
majesté saint jacques le petit verre de
vin blanc pour accompagner tout ça est
un désir
il adore les gâteaux produit un tiramisu
aux feux rouges les profits terrain un
beau flop beaucoup je me suis fié une
son bureau mac ou jazz ce serait très
très bon a osé évidemment de
d'un bon vin notre champagne la pêche en
prison l'ong l'autre il faut pas en
abuser trop
[Musique]
la paire
actuellement est la seule qui me vient
en tête là je dis aussi celle perdue en
chine un mois kallas en ce sens là je
l'écouté un bouc émissaire
au coeur de ce projet
[Musique]
chocolats fleurs
face d'une au chanteur
entre amis peut-être
[Musique]
quintaux pour lui et nous cas de pauvres
john ging donc soit rire
musique chine
[Musique]
à moi pour la fin des je t'aime ou
rédigée samedi et j'espère pouvoir
rester avec toi très très très longtemps
[Musique]